habituellement le château de jambville
accueille tout au long de l'année des
classes vertes ou encore des séminaires
fermés en raison de la crise sanitaire
l'établissement a obtenu une dérogation
de la préfecture pour ainsi permettre
aux jeunes de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
de se mettre au vert c'était compliqué
de pouvoir confiné des enfants qui ont
des parcours complexe et du coup se
confinant peut faire écho à leur propre
histoire
l'idée ça a été proposé une petite
parenthèse verdoyante l'a appelé un peu
comme ça pour les pour des groupes
d'enfants de différents établissements
profiter des espaces verts tout en
respectant les règles sanitaires en
vigueur
chaque semaine trois groupes de dix
jeunes des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine sont sur le site mais ne
se côtoient pas ici pas de télévision ni
de wifi
il n'y a pas forcément de journée type
on voit en fonction aussi des besoins
des enfants ce qu'ils ont besoin de
faire dans la journée c'est un
besoin de marcher de se défouler et il y
a de quoi faire pas moins de 52 ha
entoure le château
les familles peuvent aller vivre dans le
parc sans risque et justes en croisant
des animaux écureuils faisant et autres
bestioles qui sont en train de s'établir
dans le parc on a cette sécurité de se
dire balesi fallait faire un tour de
vélo
ils savent revenir donc celle avantages
qu'on a deux de pouvoir les laisser à
leurs occupations librement sans qu'on
soit sur leur dos parmi les activités
nature proposer la découverte des
abeilles ou encore la préparation de
repas au coin du feu
celui qui a participé à un séjour
précédent a pu revenir avec les
histoires avec ce qu'il avait vécu avec
ce qu'ils avaient partagé et du coup ils
sont impatients en fait chaque jour ils
attendent avec impatience de pouvoir
partir et ils attendent leurs dates et
leur départ donc tous les 7 9 ans ont
déjà leurs valises de prêtres depuis
deux jours ouais ça se répand en fait à
l'intérieur du centre comme étant un
lieu agréable où on passe des bons
moments à la fois avec les adultes et à
la fois avec les camarades du groupe
ces séjours d'aération doivent se
poursuivre jusqu'au 11 mai